du hast die produktion angesprochen aus
den usa wenn wir jetzt dass joe biden
der zukünftige us-präsident den die fans
production aktien möchte damit kann der
unternehmen zwingen verpflichtend ja an
dieser produktion teilzunehmen eine art
kriegswirtschaft wie man das in
deutschland kennt hältst du das für
realistisch dass so etwas auch herkommen
kann oder sind wir da noch sehr weit von
entfernt also fdp chef christian lindner
hat sie gestern weil die richtigen
fragen bei uns gefordert er hat die
kriegswirtschaft genannten halt in die
markisen wirtschaft sagte dieses fach
wort gibt es in deutschland recht nicht
es gibt auch keine richtigen
kriegswirtschaft aber paragraf 5
infektionsschutzgesetz das ist in diesem
jahr geändert worden die so genannte
dritte änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes kennt diese
möglichkeit dass der bundesminister für
gesundheit das tun kann und zwar wenn
eine nationale epidemische lage von
nationaler bedeutung festgestellt worden
ist dann könnte er das tun und war
alleine ohne dass die bundesländer daran
beteiligt werden müssten
dann könnte er anordnete sicherstellen
und andere sachen machen um die medizin
produktion aufrecht zu halten oder so
sieht sicherzustellen dass wichtige
dringend gebrauchte sachen hergestellt
werden können aber dass das in
deutschland passiert halte ich für
relativ unwahrscheinlich denn es ist zu
spät
das hätte man schon früher früher machen
müssen das hätte man dann im sommer oder
im herbst tun müssen jetzt ist java und
deckt dabei und hat ja ein neues werk
als ein werk gekauft in marburg das ist
das baut man jetzt um das läuft seit
anfang herbst und das dauert immer noch
und das dauert eben wirklich und selbst
wenn du jetzt andere verpflichtet
niemand in deutschland stellt bisher 1 1
dem stoff aus boten-rna her
das völlig neu das musste komplett neu
aufbauen das geht so schnell ich sagen
wir so es wäre der kürzere weg der
bundesgesundheitsminister bittet oder
die kanzlerin bitten führende pharma
hersteller in deutschland das auch zu
produzieren und sie bitten höflich bei
biotech die formel freiheit freizugeben
und andere herstellen zu lassen damit
wird man schneller aber auch nicht
schnell genug
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren